>>Narrator: Jeff Farden
has an enviable commute.
It's about 100 yards from his home
to his home office in
New Plymouth, Idaho.
Farden is a principal for the Idaho
Digital Learning Academy, or IDLA.
>>Jeff: See, as a principal, these
are the courses that I oversee.
>>Narrator: With funding from the
state, IDLA offers a range of courses
to middle- and high-school students
who are learning on their own
or in classes facilitated
by onsite coordinators.
>>Okay, so there you have some...
>>Jeff: As online administrators,
one of our jobs is to ensure
that the coursework and the
teachers are really up-to-date
with the daily workings of the class.
We're looking for how frequent
teachers post announcements,
the overall communications
they have with their students.
Our primary goal is to ensure
that the teachers have
the resources available
to do a good job within the class.
Getting sent to the
principal's office
in a virtual world is
a little bit different.
We obviously don't physically see
them, but if a teacher has a concern,
maybe inappropriate language, maybe
there's a question on a plagiarism,
that's something that
can be referred to us.
>>Narrator: While Farden spends most
of his time monitoring classes
virtually, he also hits the road
as a regional liaison for IDLA
and checks in at school sites
where the courses are delivered.
>>Jeff: Being a principal in
a brick-and-mortar school,
you're aware of really what teachers
have good control of their classroom.
That may be, you know, just
through the noise level,
maybe through the disciplinary
referrals that they send
to the office, whereas in an online
environment, I really have to go
in there and look at the gradebook
and monitor the discussion boards.
>>This is the only correction I have.
It looks really good.
What I want you to do
is be specific about...
>>Jeff: I really don't want to
see a teacher just tell kids,
"Great job, great job, great job."
I'm really looking for
some personalized feedback
from that teacher to make a
connection with those students,
and then also, you know, to help
point them in the right direction
for their future success.
>>Okay, let me just
see where you're at.
>>Jeff: An online course,
it's something
that you can't just let
the kids run free with.
They do still need the structure,
and they need the support to ensure
that they're learning
the content and actually
that somebody is there
to support them.
You know, hence, my role, also.
I am a level of support to really
help the teachers to therefore turn
around and help the students.
>>You can always get ahold of
Miss Sheldon, and I'm always
in here or around school.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to Edutopia.org.